pour les professionnels du tourisme en
france la crise elle se confirme après
le 11 septembre beaucoup de réservations
ont été annulées situation d'autant plus
inquiétante que la france est le premier
pays visité au monde et le tourisme
rapporte évidemment beaucoup de devises
reportage nathalie perez et michel
anglade nous sommes en plein coeur de
saint-germain-des-prés l'un des
quartiers les plus touristiques de la
capitale
le bistrot d'alex un de ses petit
restaurant cosy dont les américains
connaisseurs raffole pour ses bons vins
et sa cuisine provençale typiquement
française pourtant depuis le 11
septembre dernier cette clientèle-là à
déserter saint germain a pas plus
permettre aux enfants de faire du roman
commence aussi à moi parce que notre
clientèle
on avait une grosse clientèle problème
de touristes étrangers beaucoup
d'américains pensent qu'à saint germain
des prés afin de pas mal d'américains et
qui recherche toujours des produits haut
de gamme des bons produits des produits
français et du homard breton par exemple
ici où les tables se réservait parfois
mois al avance on a perdu près de 40% du
chiffre d'affaires
des gens me demandent quand ça va me
demander ce qu'on peut réserver ce soir
ce qui vous reste encore de la place
ils sont restés sur l'image de
restaurant qui était qu'un et et la
réalité c'est pas exactement comme ça
aujourd'hui
même chose à deux pas de là dans cet
hôtel 4 étoiles les américains sont de
plus en plus rare pas un jour sans
annulation je vais vous demander si vous
est possible de nous envoyer un fax
d'annulation voilà et suite à 100 fera
le remboursement par la compagnie on ne
veut pas qu'on nous empêche de partir en
vacances
je pense que les américains ont peur de
prendre l'avion
moi même j'ai eu un peu peur en venant
ici
le gouvernement a proposé aujourd'hui
des mesures pour ces professionnels
mais aucune aide financière directe je
pense que ça sera des mesures
temporaires de suspension peut-être de
deux taxes pour aider dans le temps les
professionnels un délai de paiement de
quelques mois pour la tva et des taxes
une mesure qui concerne toutes les
villes touristiques de france qui
aujourd'hui affiche une baisse de
fréquentation allant de 20 à 35%